what's up today I am have a guest
everybody it's surprise guest that
doesn't want to come out apparently we
practice this smarter everybody can you
do this myself today I have a challenge
for your Mars yes I'm ready
who is the best gamer which game are we
playing busy why if you guys want to
check it out and we'll link it in
description galore your sponsored video
namaste
do you see my dancing top I prepared for
these you like it no one wants to see
you dance please stop stop immediately
the point of this game I never played it
before I haven't practiced but the point
of the game is that you you sync it to
the music so you gotta listen to the
music how would you say that your tempo
skill is good that's gonna be a tough
one all right here you go you start you
start whoever makes it first
so it starts up really easy okay don't
worry buddy
[Music]
okay you got 20% Maya I'm gonna need you
to shut up
you get less points
and you did it good job Ozzie what's
thanks for you to Dooku perhaps Sadako
don't touch my nipple they have this
near level called the faded which you
may have heard the song it's very
emotional
even though technology has connected as
more than ever the whole world sometimes
you feel more disconnected and in
solitude than ever and this is what this
song in this level is all about listen
this is hard
[Music]
she's beginning to really where are you
going whoa that was sick she doesn't
hold a fling Sudoku
that's pretty good
I feel more and more disconnected the
more time goes
how are you so good it's called talent
[Music]
where am I going this is so tricky wow
this is an excellent power what
whoa let's take me
[Music]
no damn it
I was just getting good next one up to
me all right
this is for my crows let's stay with the
oldest time and maybe first what are you
doing
I can't hear you
Oh
[Music]
it's gotta listen to the music mines and
then Tony had to do
Oh
what what the hell was that
[Music]
excuse me I'm killing it
not crown yeah I got all the crowns Oh
[Music]
goodbye why are you even trying why are
you even here just I actually did it
that's pretty cool well I know I died
wasn't that awesome
yeah it's got a believe Luke Skywalker
[Music]
[Applause]
you're so short
[Music]
in my life in my life what were you
thinking - it's my side thank you for
watching this video check out dancing
line link in the description super fun
game I really enjoy it um I'm gonna try
this last time this is clearly the best
song close sighs I hate you
now recording anymore